he is just fantastic oprah winfrey is
praising prince harry
ahead of the release of their new
docu-series uh
what did you say the forever queen of
daytime sat down with ellen degeneres on
thursday
and dished on the show the me you can't
see coming to apple tv plus on may 21st
and revealed how the project with the
duke of sussex came to be
from the very first moment we had a
conversation about
um what were the two most important
issues
in the world i asked him what do you
think is the two most important issues
in the world he said climate change and
mental health
but it didn't stop there oprah also
revealed that she didn't even expect
harry to hop on board to co-produce the
series
and i started telling him about the
series i was working on um
called uh we didn't even have a name for
it just a mental health series
and as i turned to walk away he said
well if you ever need any help with that
series
i went uh the me you can't see will
focus on mental health
and maintaining a sense of wellness and
balance over the years prince harry has
been a huge advocate for mental health
for me is is is a subject of a
conversation that's just not talked
about enough
in a press release for the new show
harry says quote the majority of us
carry some form of unresolved trauma
loss or grief
which feels and is very personal the
last year has shown us that we are all
in this together
and my hope is that this series will
show there is a power invulnerability
connection and empathy and strength and
honesty
everybody has a story they have a part
of themselves that we don't know about
and recognizing that you have that and
you have that and everybody has that
the me that you cannot see i think
begins to erase the stigma
oprah and ellen also reminisced on their
talk show journeys
on wednesday ellen announced that she's
ending her daytime talk show
next year the past 18 years
you have to know has changed my life you
all have changed my life and i am
forever grateful to all of you for
watching
oprah of course hosted the oprah winfrey
show from 1986 to 2011
for a total of 25 seasons the tv veteran
commended ellen for knowing when it was
time to quit
i'm proud of you for trusting your
instinct because i know that there has
to be as there was in the case for me a
lot of people around you
who want to keep that train moving who
want you to keep going
and then only you know
only you know when it is time and
although we have a while before we
officially say goodbye to ellen on tv
she assures us that she won't be gone
for long i had a vivint dream
that that a bird flew out of a cage and
set itself free because it needed to get
out of that cage and
recently i had a dream that a bird
beautiful bird with bright red feathers
came to my window and whispered
you can still do stuff on netflix and
that was the sign i was looking for
you